salut à toi jeune entrepreneur si
aujourd'hui je me paierais te contacter
c'est pour une raison très simple je
vais parler de charles ponzi qui a
escroqué 30000 personnes à hauteur de 10
millions de dollars quand même à boston
dans les années 20 de bernard madoff qui
pendant 48 ans a mis en place une
arnaque qui a pris une ampleur
hallucinante à hauteur de 50 milliards
d'euros qu'ont en commun toutes ces
organisations le système pyramidal
l'idée très simple je vais prendre tout
est sous pour te rembourser et gagne et
aussi des sous tu vas prendre des sous d
autres gens qui devront aussi trouver
d'autres gens pour prendre leur saoul
qui me donneront ils jettent ordonnerait
une partie c'est simple alors est ce que
tu veux faire partie des 5 % du sommet
de ma pire ami qui arnaquent 95% des
autres moi je crois que la question il
est répandu
loïc génériques fadi générique un
système pyramidal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord qu'est-ce qui définit un système
pyramidal en fait il s'agit d'une
escroquerie comme ça c'est clair pour
tout le monde
escroquerie dans laquelle l'initiateur
de la pyramide à vis des investisseurs à
effectuer une dépense plus ou moins
importants qu'il invite ensuite ces
investisseurs a recruté à leur tour des
nouveaux entrants qui vont eux-mêmes
effectué la même dépense et les
versements des nouveaux entrants vont
servir à rémunérer en priorité les
intérêts des premiers investisseurs de
la pyramide et après on redescend un
petit peu et ainsi de suite
donc les étages supérieurs de la
pyramide recevront des montants de plus
en plus importants tandis que la
pyramide elle elle continuer à recruter
mais cette progression ne peut pas être
infinie ne serait ce parce qu'il ya un
nombre limité d'êtres humains sur terre
n'empêche que ça ferait déjà une sacrée
pyramide si tout le monde y participer
c'est le principe de l'ex potentiel on a
déjà vu ça dans des vidéos ensemble si
on considère qu à chaque étage de la
pyramide il faut recruter deux fois plus
de personnes que les tâches précédent
alors ça devient l'échiquier de 6 à
j'avais fait une vidéo là dessus en 2016
je la mets dans la description au
cinquième rang la pyramide il ya déjà
trente et une personnes dans la pierre
ni dans le système et au 64e rang de la
pyramide il y a ce chiffre-là qui est
clairement imprononçable en fait ces
deux milliards deux fois le nombre
d'habitants qui a sur terre en seulement
64 étages de la pierre mais lorsque la
pyramide ne peut plus s'étendre qu'elle
peut plus recruter alors les étages
inférieurs ne peuvent plus recruter de
nouveaux membres et les tâches qui est
juste au-dessus perd toute leur mise
mais c'est pas très grave parce qu'il
reste encore peut-être d'autres
personnes est en fait le pas de la
pyramide lui se met dans une galère
tandis que le haut de la pyramide
ça va ça va je reviens ils sont pas être
impacté par les coûts loin du système
ils se sont déjà enrichi dès le début
sur le dos des premiers membres des
étages inférieurs autrement dit ils s'en
sont mis plein les poches tout va bien
en général les ventes pyramidales un peu
d'églises et propose une gamme de
produits assez simple généralement sans
marque ou ou assez méconnu du grand
public ou très inhabituel ce qui rend
leur valeur marchande difficile à
évaluer pour l'investisseur - le nouvel
entrant icaunais dans le domaine du
produit plus il va être facile de lui
retourner un peu le cerveau mais il
existe même des systèmes pyramidaux sans
aucun produit alors ça c'est fabuleux
ils appellent ça des cercles d'abondance
ou des cercles de richesse en gros ça se
joue à la confiance le but c'est
d'arriver au centre du cercle qui
regroupe une quinzaine de personnes pour
récupérer environ 80000 euros pour
commencer on doit verser dix mille euros
et
général ses valises de cash de 10000
euros il n'y a pas de compte bancaire et
on doit trouver en même temps de
nouveaux entrants qui rentre avec nous
donc comme ça tu embarques bien deux
copains ou deux personne de ta famille a
galéré à larguer comme ça dix mille
euros peut-être les économies d'une vie
et ensuite belle but du jeu c'est de
trouver une personne qui va elle aussi
rentrer dans le cercle donc à l'étagé
inférieur à toi et qui va aussi emmené
deux personnes avec elle et c'est là où
toi tu vas changer le cercle et te
rapprocher un petit peu du centre les
structures pyramidales sont illégales
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
les systèmes pyramidaux ne crée aucune
richesse aucune valeur l'argent il pas
simplement des rangs les plus bas au
rang supérieur jusqu'au sommet de la
pyramide qui elle se fait abondamment
servir à chaque fois la seconde raison
c'est que les systèmes pyramidaux sont
comme vous avez compris précaire est
donc voué mathématiquement à l'échec
soyons clairs ça peut paraître sexy ça
peut pas être faisable
intellectuellement mais c'est impossible
mathématiquement que ça fonctionne dans
le temps pour trouver des nouvelles
recrues
les membres des systèmes pyramidaux ont
tendance à chercher autour d'eux des
gens qui acceptent de leur faire
confiance et donc qui accepte d'investir
une certaine somme en échange de
promesses de fortune futur ou de revenus
réguliers pour y parvenir
ses membres font appel au marketing de
réseau donc bien souvent s'est réduit à
la famille et aux amis proches donc ça
crée des tensions dans la vie en plus la
vente car migdal c'est donc immoral elle
se contente pas de vous arnaquer elle
encourage ses membres a profité de son
entourage de tata jojo de tonton loïc ça
ton temps tu dois il dit au sort des
fenêtres pour résumer une organisation
fait de la vente pyramidale si les
participants font leurs moules à grâce
au recrutement avec investissement de
départ évidemment et non pas avec la
vente réelle des biens et des services
aux consommateurs
[Musique]
en 1919 charles ponzi 37 ans italien
domicilié à boston aux états unis
il cherche des fonds pour lancer un
magazine qui seraient consacrées à
l'export alors qui correspond avec
l'étranger ils découvrent à l'intérieur
d'une led venus d'espagne un coupon
réponse internationale
cr il remarque ce coupon a été payée en
pc tu as donc l'équivalent de 1 cents
américains
or à l'époque ce coupon peut être
échangé dans une poste de boston contre
un timbre de six cents soit six fois la
valeur du scr it départ et c'est sur ces
écarts de change que ponzi décide de
faire de l'argent le 26 décembre 1919
charles créer une société qui s'appelle
the security exchange compagnie l'idée
annoncé ses clients c'est d'investir de
l'argent de départ qui est rémunéré à
hauteur de 50% tous trois mois grâce au
change de série ça ça fonctionne sur le
principe par exemple nicolas
investissant dollars en janvier
ponzi fait son bail avec les séries et
en mars nicolas récupère 100 50 de la
sas tiens ça se tient tellement que dans
la vraie vie ça fonctionne au bout de
trois mois les premiers clients
reçoivent l'argent de leurs intérêts il
dit alors que le système de ponzi
fonctionne bien et début juillet 1920
c'est trente mille clients qui ont déjà
déposé plus de 10 millions de dollars
aux bureaux de la compagnie panzi en
poche à cette période jusqu'à un million
de dollars par semaine dans les poches
de sa société sils sommes absolument
faramineuses pour l'époque parce que
c'est pas les mêmes valeurs en fonction
des époques tout ça mais en juillet 1920
le boston poste fait un article qui va
semer la panique chez tous les
investisseurs de chez panzi clarence
baron analyste financier écrit que seuls
27 mille coupons postaux séries sont en
circulation aux états unis soit 133
millions de moins que ce qu'il aurait
fallu à ponzi pour investir tout
l'argent que les investisseurs avaient
mis chez lui aucune grosse panique
il ya de nombreux investisseurs qui
commencent à comprendre quelque chose
qui cloche et il retire tout leur argent
quand ils remboursent 2 millions de
dollars en deux jours et le 26 juillet
1920 il encaisse encore jusqu'à 200
mille dollars par semaine
quand enfin le procureur joseph
pelletier demande à ce que ponzi arrête
le recrutement de nouveaux clients
donc il a plus de nouveaux clients qui
rentrent chez lui et là c'est un souci
parce que les dons capsié plus d'argent
en entrant il pu le sortir le boston
poste enfonce le clou en août en
écrivant que ponzi a déjà fait de la
prison c'est le retour de la panique et
der demande de remboursement
de tout l'argent toute l'âme ou là qui
était chez lui fonzie commence alors à
remplir des chèques alors des clients
mécontents mais là où sa hotte bien ouf
c'est que la commission bancaire voit
une catastrophe arrivée et commence même
à craindre pour le système bancaire de
l'état c'est hallucinant qui pourrait
s'écrouler si panzi se mettaient à
rembourser tous ces épargnants d'un seul
coup donc les chèques émis par tandis
sont volontairement refusé par les
banques
et si à la mi août que l'escroquerie
éclate officiellement au grand jour sous
toutes ses coutures en gros tanzi payer
bien les intérêts de tout le monde
simplement les intérêts pas la mise de
départ avec une partie de l'argent des
nouveaux épargnants
donc on avait l'impression que le
système était opérationnel mais à partir
du moment où il ya plus de nouveaux
épargnants où tout le monde voulait
retire en même temps la pyramide
s'effondre charles a été emprisonné
condamné à cinq ans de prison il en fera
au final que trois la nationalité
américaine lui a été refusée me restera
tout de même aux états unis et les morts
ruiner en amérique latine en 1949 à
l'âge de 66 ans la fere madoff c'est un
autre exemple qui illustre la taille
gigantesque que peut avoir un système
pyramidal bernard madoff c'est la
légende de wall street il a réussi à
créer et administrer une chaîne de ponzi
de 1960 à 2008 il n'y a pas si longtemps
pendant 48 ans il a réussi à faire
fonctionner un réseau en promettant un
retour sur investissement de 12 % à ses
clients ce qui est énorme dans le milieu
bancaire
parce que c'était un taux fixe et sur
soi disant sûr selon bernard en 1960
madoff à 22 ans il a 5000 $ dans ses
poches et créer un fonds
d'investissements alors au départ tout
est légal madoff reçurent les capitaux
de ses clients il aimait dans des fonds
d'investissement à risque dont la
performance est réputée comme étant
supérieur à la moyenne mais c'est là où
ça commence déjà à déconner quand les
gains obtenus étaient en dessous de la
rentabilité qu'il avait un peu promis à
ses clients au lieu de réduire le
montant distribué aux investisseurs un
truc à risque madoff prenez l'argent des
nouveaux entrants pour les rémunérer et
ça ça a été le début de sa pierre me
mais vous allez voir l'histoire folle
puisque madoff tenait en apparence et
promesses sa réputation grossistes et et
les nouveaux entrants arrivés avec une
forte somme en plus pour entrer dans le
système pour entrer dans le système il
fallait au mieux être parrainés et quoi
qu'il arrive
beaucoup de pognon d'un coup ça roule
pendant 48 ans et c'est la crise
financière de 2008 qui a vraiment raison
du système madoff alors que les bourses
les différentes bourses qui a dans le
monde s'effondre il ya de nombreux
investisseurs qui demandent à l'homme
d'affaires de récupérer leur argent
parce qu'ils se disent ça va partir en
fumée avec la crise et c'est peine
perdue puisque cet argent il existe déjà
pas il a servi chaque année à payer les
intérêts de ces mêmes investisseurs en
fait madoff prévient alors son fils qui
provient lui-même les autorités et le
fbi à y embarquent madoff je raccourcis
l'histoire il ya plein de documentaires
que je vous invite à regarder sur
l'histoire de bernard madoff
ce qui est intéressant c'est que madoff
aurait fraudé l'ensemble de ses victimes
pour un montant de plus de 65 milliards
de dollars et que parmi elles on pouvait
compter des fondations comme celle de
steven spielberg en france et à des
sociétés comme bnp paribas axa le crédit
agricole groupama la société générale
qui en ont fait les frais qu'ils avaient
investie dessus les petits épargnants
français eux auraient été touchés à
hauteur du coût de 40 millions d'euros
puisque les banques comme ça avec
l'argent des petits épargnants de france
et à les investir ensuite directement
chez madoff mais du coup ceux qui sont
fait vraiment à voir c'est ce qui avait
mis leur argent des parents madoff a été
condamné à 150 ans et beaucoup de
prisons et aujourd'hui il est bien sûr
ruiner pour l'anecdote madoff s'est
recyclé en prison comme étant parrain du
marché du chocolat chaud auprès des
autres détenus il est incarcéré en
caroline du nord il a mis en place un
système où il achète tous les produits
de la marque swiss miss il le fait en
direct directement auprès de
l'intendance d'établissements
pénitentiaires et ensuite ils les
revendre plus cher dans la cour voilà on
se refait pas on pourrait penser
aujourd'hui que ce système est légal et
est connu de tout le monde et n'existe
plus mais c'est complètement faux ces
dernières années il ya plusieurs
entreprises qui ont été pointés du doigt
parce qu'elle était soupçonnée
d'utiliser ce même si sts leur réseau se
développe de plus en plus vite pourquoi
parce que maintenant il ya les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est hyper actif il perd
rapide ya la création de faux comptes
des publicités mensongères ou simplement
des personnes que vous connaissez dans
votre entourage dans vos amis qui du
jour au lendemain vous propose du
maquillage et des produits pour la santé
je suis sûr vous avez déjà vu passer ça
les premières victimes ce sont les
nouveaux entrants et c'est
principalement des gens qui sont à la
recherche d'un revenu complémentaire et
la plupart du temps aussi qu'ils sont un
petit peu près qu'à ses limites du
mentalisme ans on leur propose de
rentrer dans un réseau pour avoir des
réductions sur un pack de produits
introuvables ailleurs mais un
peu coûteux et après une fois qu'ils
sont qu'ils ont acheté le pack on leur
explique que le simple fait de recruter
des nouvelles personnes dans ce même
réseau leur permet de gagner de l'argent
et de toucher un pourcentage pour chaque
parrainage et qu'au final c'est quand
même bien plus rentable que de vendre
des produits qu'ils avaient acheté si
cher c'est vraiment un droit d'entrée
déguisée sous des produits pour la
société it works par exemple qui vend
principalement des produits beauté et
minceur il est demandé aux nouveaux
entrants d'acheter un pack de
présentation et ensuite de recruter de
nouveaux collaborateurs 10e aussi vont
acheter leur pack de présentation et
ainsi de suite
on retrouve donc bel et bien le système
pyramidal de départ cacher derrière des
produits qui au final ne se vendre que
très peu ils sont juste une parade un
peu légal qui marche sur le fil de
l'album il arrive donc régulièrement que
des consommateurs qui avait été
approchée dans un premier temps pour
acheter des produits soient amenés à
devenir eux mêmes distributeurs ne
serait ce que pour obtenir les
réductions sur l'achat des produits qu
eux-mêmes consomme pour leur
consommation personnelle cette affaire a
été rendue publique par l'investisseur
et activiste bill ackman hackman c'est
un investisseur américain qui créé en
2004 le fonds d'investissement pershing
chère capitale en 2012 il alors 46 ans
il investit depuis son fonds à lui 1
milliard de dollars pour parier sur le
fait karbalaï va tout simplement
s'écrouler la raison selon lui la
société ne vaut rien puisqu'elle est
fondé sur un système pyramidal et dans
les dix jours qui suivent cette annonce
la valeur boursière d'erba life chute de
moitié ses énormes
la société se défend et michael johnson
qui est le directeur général
à ce moment là d'un même jusqu'aux
menaces en disant que l'amérique ne se
portera que mieux quand elle sera
débarrassé de bill ackman donc c'est une
vraie guerre dans les médias qui
poussera d'ailleurs hackman à s'offrir
les services d'une protection rapprochée
parce que ben il ya beaucoup trop de
gens qui sont dans la société am alive
si une guerre de ouf qu'a lieu je vous
invite à regarder sur internet et
coupures de presse de l'époque entre
herbalife et l'activiste hackman mais en
2016 et la commission du commerce
américaine ftc qui était alors chargé
depuis deux ans de déterminer si
herbalife proposé sur une pyramide de
ponzi ou pas ne suis pas hackman elle
considère pas car bas live suivent un
système pyramidal il ya un accord qui
prévoit quand même par contre que la
société arbalète vers 200 millions de
dollars et carros rupture en profondeur
ses activités pour que les membres
soient récompensés en priorité pour ce
qu'ils vendent et non pas pour le nombre
de personnes qu'ils recrutent autour
d'eux les pyramides de pan
ou encore de beaux jours devant elle
soixante pyramide de ponzi ont été
découverts aux états unis en 2010 neuf
c'est comme ça tous les ans donc il ya à
peu près une clé démantelé par semaine
ça représente 3,24 milliards $ d'argent
escroqué tous les ans selon les
estimations
et encore je dois est en dessous de la
vérité parce que le montant collecté
auprès des investisseurs
un peu naïf ou qui se font avoir a
doublé par rapport à 2018
et ça ça s'explique encore une fois avec
les réseaux sociaux les arnaques se
porte sur l'immobilier sur des panneaux
solaires sur des diamants sur des crypto
monnaies et sur des produits de beauté
est comme gelée déjà dit plus les
placements sont atypiques
- les investisseurs s'y connaissent et
moins ils se méfient du coup et tant
qu'il y aura des nouveaux marchés à
conquérir les pyramides de ponzi
continueront de fleurir sauf si le monde
entier est informé du fonctionnement de
ces pyramides
auquel cas plus personne ne se ferait à
voir ce que vous voyez où je veux en
venir donc n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo à une personne qui elle même
devra recruter deux personnes qui
partageront cette vidéo est encore deux
personnes deux personnes un vrai plus
sera vue - il y aura potentiellement de
victimes
et si vous voyez un jour quelqu'un de
votre entourage qui se lancent deux
dents sur facebook ou ailleurs la
question les beats répondu vous lui
faites voir cette vidéo
ça va être dur à accepter surtout si il
ou elle a acheté un pack au départ mais
en vrai vous allez lui rendre service
n'oubliez pas de laisser reliques à
cette vidéo je m'appelle toujours
toujours fabien olicard toujours ou pas
oui ok ok fabian le cas donc abonnez
vous à cette vidéo choc abonnez vous à
cette chaîne youtube c'est gratuit pour
ses activés la cloche sinon pour hâter
les vidéos quand elles sortent et c'est
dommage c'est juste à côté du bouton
abonnement vous pouvez me rejoindre sur
les autres réseaux c'est complémentaire
ya tik tok et instagram ya plein de
choses il ya tout chez tous ici je vous
mets deux autres vidéos l'acsl sur
l'échiquier de 6 à donc vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure c'est pas si simple à
dire un effectif de 6 à et là c'est sur
une arnaque qui a été fait pour voler
des diamants il ya assez longtemps en
utilisant des méthodes de mentalist je
pense que si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
vous allez aimer ces deux là à très
bientôt tout cas ciao ciao